hey there Hulu fans I'm Mae Whitman and
I'm Carlos Valdez and we star in the
brand new musical series up here if you
love Stephen Levinson's writing God
knows I do if you love rom-coms if you
love the year 1999 we've got your new
favorite show yeah you get to watch our
characters Lindsay and Miguel fall in
love in New York City as they try to
overcome the obstacles that could keep
them apart make sure to watch up here
and stick around to see what other shows
and movies are coming to Hulu this month
[Music]
thank you
New York is where real writers live I
belong in this city you've been hit by
three cabs at very low speeds it's
different with Lindsay because she's
special that is actually very sweet all
those voices floating in her head they
don't see what I do
my life is a mess my husband kicked me
out a few days ago
my daughter hates me you're one of the
best writers I know an advice column is
easy clicks I'm not giving anybody
advice
I want so much for you but you're not
gonna get any of it if you don't want it
for yourself what does it mean to heal
to move on to let go the car cougars are
going for a fifth consecutive state
championship high accelerations was to
build the best team in America when we
lost him it changed our message of our
program
people think it's all about football but
it's really about the lessons that you
learn
we have to
[Applause]
enemies
that's me
I'm gonna meet my ex for the first time
since the breakup you're still calling
it B breakup I went through the same
sort of thing not too long ago foreign
sometimes you just gotta see what
happens
go where the breeze takes you
[Music]
the problem is is it that I've got a
fatty deposit the size of a giant gourd
on my back
Hunchback morning
not another God kill that one send a
warning shot shoot over the heads yes
Lord whoops
[Applause]
I'm engaged oh my God
what are we doing for the bachelorette
party it's female Fight Club we grease
up surprise beat the crap out of us
[Music]
ready
to party
oh yeah
25 million on the table so I just
thought we'd up the stakes tonight
raise 175.
I hope this is another one of your
surprises Jake
life's just a game right
stay in the game
and he'll just die she's never gonna
rate US into her will she doesn't like
us she doesn't like anybody until
we heard you weren't well oh cousin
Beatrice is here I was just out buying
flowers for my favorite aunt they're
trying to take our money
what the hell is wrong with you people
we are going to pull off the True Crime
of the century
gadgets
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
when I was young I was blinded by love
now look on what remains of me you can
break his heart all she taught me was
how to be her weapon of Revenge
everything I tell you to do
my name is Tupac Shakur and I'm 17 years
old it was my responsibility to teach
Tupac How to Survive his reality
Affinity was his hero and it's really
hard to see your hero fall he was
suffering and fainey wanted the story
told blemishes and all
welcome to the tour you're like my
favorite rapper how is the search for
love going I mean I had such high hopes
I'm so happy that I get to see America
for what it is
you don't know my values maybe we have
more in common than you might think why
don't you just tell me what they are
uh mom what are our values look I'm not
gonna lie to you it's all triggering I
still live with my mother
space I get it I have the first real job
I've had in years I'm sorry about that
it's fine I'm kind of into it but I have
a sponsor and a real Community look at
you two back on your heteronormative
Bulls
I came here to be pushed out of my
culinary comfort zone I don't carry
purses but if I have to carry a purse of
watercress I will we're real good
it's not always about how far you go
it's about making things human wow
cheers
you guys have created something very
magical here
elephants are more like us
seek to each other in ways we're just
beginning to understand
they'll share their secrets with us if
we only listen
are we on TV now I'm back in the acting
game what a rush
[Music]
affection can't believe in this climate
we're still calling you guys ladybugs
guys really
[Music]